hi guys in the first part of this video
but basically gonna explain night eyes
quirk which I would describe is one of
the most supernatural powers in the show
in the second part we're gonna have a
spoiler free examination on the
character himself basically delving into
his backstory his motivation and stuff
like that and the final part is
specifically for those of you who have
read the manga or just don't care about
season four spoilers we're gonna briefly
talk about the ramifications of his
actions moving forward into season five
and beyond but very quickly before we
begin at this moment I have a decent
amount of character explanation videos
on my channel so if you love my ear
academia I would definitely recommend
subscribing okay let's get into the
first part of this video now in the
intro just then I referred to night eyes
quirk as more supernatural than others
in the series I'll be the first to
acknowledge that yes all quirks in my
hero academia are supernatural when
compared to the real world but for the
most part I'd say that quirks generally
stay within a boundary where I can
suspend my disbelief for example
mutation quirks like Kirishima or
superpowers like deco
although powers like these are obviously
not real and probably never will be real
I understand how they could be real if
that makes sense whereas some of the
quirks are more supernatural such as
dark shadow I just look at dark shadow
and I'm like how does this exist how is
that possible I guess what I'm trying to
say is that some quirks seem more cosmic
than others and I think Knight ice quirk
is one of those more cosmic powers so
night eyes power is called foresight and
it basically grants him the ability to
accurately see into the future of any
person he chooses but I'd say with this
quirk more than any other there is a lot
of conditions and stipulations that
we're about to get into
okay so firstly when he uses foresight
on a person he can't see into their
future from a third-person perspective
and during these visions he can
basically see the person themself and
their immediate surroundings but not
much detail beyond that and I think it's
important to note that he can't actually
hear anything in these visions either
and he apparently has no limit on how
far into the future you can see but
there is the little stipulation that he
can't actually give precise dates as to
when things will happen and the further
into the future he looks the less
accurate his estimations become so on a
separate note night eye is adamant that
his visions cannot be changed as
everything that he is predicted has
always come to
and we'll get into that later because it
actually affects the decisions that he
makes on his day-to-day life regarding
how he uses his quirk furthermore
another stipulation that surrounds this
quirk is that he can only see into the
targets future for one hour and once
he's used it he can't use it again for
another 24 hours so as far as powers ago
this one has a lot of rules and I kind
of feel bad for him the final thing to
know regarding his quirk is that he
activates it when he physically touches
a person and then makes eye contact with
them he has to make eye contact and I
gotta say he uses this power in really
clever ways not just to see far into the
future but also to see someone's
immediate future and then predict what
moves they're about to make and then
based on that data he can react and
counter those moves so I'd say it's
pretty useful for combat actually okay
so now we finished talking about his
quirk specifically let's get into night
I as a person and yes this is the second
part of the video as a person night I is
incredibly intelligent which kind of
compensates for the fact that he rarely
ever uses his quirk
he's pretty reluctant to use foresight
as he believes that anything he sees
however positive or negative is
guaranteed to happen for that reason he
prefers to use his brains his intellect
to get situations under his control and
then once he's done that he can use
foresight to confirm that things will
remain under control now to this day
night I remains a big big fan of all my
much like deku he collects all my
memorabilia watches old all my YouTube
videos like he's pretty pretty hardcore
in fact he loved all my so much that he
repeatedly begged him to be his sidekick
something which all might refused but
eventually after much much more begging
or my gave in and and basically allowed
Nara to fill out his paperwork
eventually though they did work together
as a proper superhero team for five
years and that I sort of acted as the
intellect behind all my hero activities
during their partnership and because of
this relationship night I is one of the
only people to know the truth about one
for all which is obviously the power
that all my has which he passed on to
Deku following on from that knowledge he
believes that his apprentice miryo was
the most logical successor for that
power something which actually I agree
with although Deku is a hundred percent
fit to have the power and I obviously
I love deku but I got to say if it was
given to me Rio if you've noticed when
Mario is using his power as we saw when
he fought the entirety of class 1-a his
main finishing moves the things that he
does to incapacitate people is punch
them so if that was combined with one
for all he would be disgustingly
powerful like it wouldn't even it would
just be insane but when comparing deco
and mario while stack who does
definitely i think have more of the
heart of a hero I think Mario with all
for one oh sorry one for all he would
just be so powerful and he is very
heroic himself so I think overall
everything considered me Rio is the
worthy successor and in fact it was
under sanitized teachings the Miria went
from an average student to the number
one student at UA within the space of a
single year so after sir Knight I
stopped being all my sidekick he became
a pro hero in his own right and actually
set up his own agency and within that
agency he keeps the details of his for
psych work a complete secret and this is
a pretty strategic and smart move
because most villains don't know what
he's capable of and although his
personality can appear cold on the
surface he actually greatly values humor
and kind of refuses to acknowledge
people that can't make him laugh and so
that brings us to the end of the spoiler
free part of this video I really hope
you enjoyed it and if you're leaving us
now then please like and subscribe
I specifically left a few things out of
this section just to minimize anything
that someone might think is a spoiler
but I'm pretty sure there's enough
information in this video so far to get
an idea of what his power is and
obviously who he is okay so let's talk
about the ramifications of two or
sanada's predictions and the fact that
we now know that under certain
circumstances his visions can be changed
so we all know that night I predicted
that Deku would be killed by overall and
that he believed that this was
inevitable now the fact that it didn't
happen is quite important to know why it
didn't happen what I mean to say is that
if Deku was only able to define night as
visions because era was altering time in
some way then that means going forward
nya's remaining predictions still can't
be changed contrarily if they could defy
this vision out of sheer perseverance
then what is clear is that the future
that night i sees it can be changed
without the need for time manipulation
so if this is the case it means two
things firstly if you remember in season
three when all might basically declare
to all for one that he wouldn't die by
shigga Rocky's hands well that actually
might be true because if nite ize
predictions can be avoided by sheer
force of will there is no one who has
more force of will than all my let's
just take a second to appreciate this
one fact all might was told by night I
that he would die by the hands of a
powerful villain now this happened
before we ever met war might it happened
before the story began now all might
never had a specific date of when this
would happen
but he knew it would happen either this
year or the next year right and so when
the big battle in Kamino with all four
one happened that was within the time
frame that night I gave that all my
would be killed by a powerful villain
and so from almost perspective that was
probably the time before he was gonna
die that's probably what he believed
night I saw it would only be logical to
think that and yet despite that he still
pulled through he gave it everything he
had and in fact when we were reading
this or watching this battle on screen
we had no idea about not as prediction
but if we did I'm sure all of us would
have been thinking this is it he has to
die now and yet despite all of that he
still pulled through like he always does
because nobody has more world than war
might and so I know horikoshi won't do
this but in theory that fighting Kamino
could have been the prediction that
night I saw it fits in world with the
timeline that he gave and all-4-one
definitely matches the description of a
powerful villain but being real the
worst is probably still yet to come but
what do you think this vision of his
horrible death is it truly inevitable
finally regarding Mireille he looked
into Maria's future and foresaw that he
would become a great hero despite the
fact that Mireille lost his permeation
quirk now myrio is on hiatus from his
studies at UA so he's not studying right
now and I just got to think if he
doesn't get his quark back within let's
say the next year I don't know exactly
how he's gonna go back to UA and pass
all the various hero exams and stuff
without any quirk obviously miryo is
completely amazing and I think he was
almost designed to be sort of this
perfect character but the fact that he's
lost his quirk I don't see how he can
finish his studies at UA
and if he doesn't graduate I don't know
I don't know if it's allowed that he can
become a hero I'm pretty sure he can't
but someone let me know my initial
theory when miryo lost his quark was
that he would remain quark list and save
people in other
such as maybe becoming a cop or
something like that but the fact that
night I made this prediction it really
makes me wonder is it possible that
perhaps mirrior becomes a vigilante in
the future because a vigilante is
essentially a type of hero you're still
saving people regardless but what do you
guys think will miryo get his quirk back
eventually and I hope he does but I just
don't know because it would reverse the
impact of that moment when he lost it
and let's be honest we know that Dec who
will be the number one hero one day
so if Miriah is back on the scene
they're not that different in age but
Mario is is in a different league right
now but then again we have to consider
that deck who obviously has probably the
best clock in the series or second best
quirk
so maybe that's not so much of a factor
but anyway I've gone off on a complete
tangent the main thing I want to hear
from you guys today is this can the
future be changed without time
manipulation and will myrio get his
quirk back remember to write spoilers in
all caps at the top of your comment so
that the people who only watch the anime
can avoid your comment and remember I
reply to every single comment so please
let me know I want to know your
rationale for whether you agree or
disagree with me and that is the end of
the third part of this video which
nicely wraps up the whole video so thank
you to everyone who retweeted the last
video that I put out the usernames are
all currently on screen as usual and
massive shout out to Kellan Gough who
plays overhaul in season 4 shout out to
him for retweeting my last video which
was overhauled explained in two minutes
thank you guys and I'll see you next
week